I don't know, I always would say
I'd get a Chinese symbol.
This was like my big joke
when I was like oh
I'll get a Chinese symbol
that means Chinese symbol.
Oh I was gonna get one
that meant unoriginal.
I honestly researched it.
I like that. Really?
I went to a Chinese restaurant
and was like, could you guys ...
that's my research,
I asked them what is
the symbol for unoriginal
and they couldn't give it to me.
They didn't understand.
We don't have such a stupid word
in our language.
Yeah they kinda said that.
Well Jews aren't allowed
to have tattoos.
Right.
So my mother would always
tell me that
but then she had her eyelids,
she had permanent eyelids.
Right.
So those are tattoos.
Not eyelids, eyeliner.
I think you mean eyeliner.
Eyeliner, yeah.
She had permanent eyes.
We'll get there,
we'll always get there.
She tattooed her eyes.
He may not get us there
but we'll get there.
As a team, as a family,
we'll get there.
You're my favorite.
It takes a village to understand
what the hell
Andrew is talking about.
My mom-
So your mom got-
I'm good for radio.
Your mom got make up tattooed
onto her eyelids
which I think is a great-
That's a tattoo though.
Yeah, it is a tattoo.
That's definitely a tattoo.
Yeah, she's not going to heaven.
And she's like you can't have
a tattoo
and I was like you have
a tattoo, eyelids,
and you have a facelift.
You changed your whole,
no one even knows if you died
you're a different person.
But I can't have a tattoo
because I can't get
buried with it.
But that eye make up means ...
what would you have gotten if
you wouldn't have felt anything?
A tattoo of her telling me
not to get a tattoo.
No, I don't know
what I would have gotten.
I would have probably gotten my
grandpa's initials or something.
I don't know, somewhere
on my forearm or something.
What are his initials?
I don't even know. HG I guess.
HG Wells.
HG and then there's MC.
Okay yeah that's what
you're gonna be
for the rest of your life too.
So that will be a good one.
I heard Angelina Jolie being ...
remember Angelina Jolie
did Dateline or something,
some big interview after
she and Billy Bob broke up.
And she said I realized
when I needed to break up
with him
when I had gotten ...
she had gotten his name
tattooed on her
and then she was thinking
I would never tattoo
Maddox's name,
her adopted son's name
on herself.
And then she's like why did
I tattoo his name,
why did I do Billy Bob but I
would never tattoo my son's
because I know I will always
have a relationship with my son.
It's not threatened.
And there was something
really interesting in that,
if you somehow worry
about a connection with someone
or you have an insecurity
about someone,
you tattoo their name-
Marriage-
... like Johnny Depp
and Winona Ryder.
And Pete Davidson
and Ariana Grande.
Any kind of official thing-
It's like proof it exists.
Honestly marriage
even is like ...
I got you, forever okay.
I get it. I want that.
That's so funny
because my ex,
who we were never
gonna get married,
I was like I want
to get tattoos.
I wanted something
in writing on us
that was we're bound for life.
You find a way to ...
you're so right.
That's why we're gonna get
tattoos when your special,
when you record it, we're gonna
get matching ones right?
What kind are you guys
gonna get?
Yeah what are we getting again?
She looks so terrified.
You brought it up, remember.
It's his joke that we're gonna
get matching tattoos
to celebrate my special which he
has been helpful with it.
Why are you having anything
to do with this Andrew.
Why not, why wouldn't
I be involved.
I remember one time
Sabrina Jalees,
and I were gonna get tattoos
if we made it through
on Last Comic Standing,
past the semis.
We told the NBC cameras
we're gonna get tattoos tonight
if we get Last Comic
Standing, if we get past, thank
God we didn't because
we would have done it.
We would have done it.
And I remember we were joking
what would we get
and Greg Giraldo
was one of the judges
and we were like we'll get
Greg Giraldo's face tattooed
on our ass.
Could you imagine
if that was ...
because knowing
what happened.
It would be a nice tribute
I guess.
Did you get to the semi-finals?
I got to the semis
but I didn't get-
So you didn't?
No we both got to that night
but no, maybe, I don't remember.
I just ... no, yes, no, yes.
Would you get like the best
looking version of Greg Giraldo?
Who picks the picture?
I don't know.
I would never have gotten
Greg Giraldo's face.
I mean it would be more
fitting now that he's gone.
My step-brother has
so many tattoos
and they all mean something.
Really?
Well he loves fishing,
he's very simple,
he lives in Florida,
he has a fish, a rattlesnake,
his cousin that died
in a motorcycle accident,
his last name and a wave,
like surfing.
Wow.
These are the exact things,
and he lives these things,
I just don't-
He is that.
When I was talking about
the accountant
with a skull that's bleeding,
it's like what is ...
Yeah you're right.
You're just trying ...
Oh my God I went out
with a guy like that once.
We went on two dates.
I just remember he worked
in the financial district
or on Wall Street
or something.
He was an investment guy
and he was fully tattooed
and he had this whole
double life kind of.
He was like a motorcycle guy
with a beard
but he wore a suit every day,
a three piece suit with a vest.
But he did ride a motorcycle.
I'm literally turned on by all
those tattoos
you just described.
The fish?
I like that they-
I've showed you my step-brother,
he's a hot man.
Yeah he has a purpose.
He knows what he his,
he's leaning into it.
I like it. I take back
everything I said about tattoos.
I either want them
to have a ridiculous story
or I want them to be
so meaningful and stupid.
But also still stupid,
but very meaningful.
So you're not into like
ornate stuff.
It's the same thing as someone
who had tattoos
when they were 18
and it meant something.
As long as there was
a funny story associated
and it really,
truly meant something to you,
I think it's kind
of a good thing.
He has a wave
because he just likes water?
Because he likes surfing.
He has a surfer,
him cutting back
with the splash of the wave.
He has a bionic,
I don't know,
the rattlesnake's bad ass
and his name is Jake
and he goes by Jake the Snake.
So then he has a rattlesnake.
It's all there and
it's coiled up ready to attack.
And he would always get mad
at me if I go near his-
I would get a hummus platter.
A hummus platter down this side
and then I'm gonna do-
A little oil, a little pita,
extra cucumbers.
Yeah, what else do
I love so much.
My phone.
Starbucks?
Right here. Starbucks down here.
Right in the middle
of your boobs.
Down there.
Something across your collar
bone would be cool.
Just like a word.
Me so latte?
You love that Hitachi
magic wand.
Just a finger.
Just a finger there.
And then a blunt to really show
how cool you are dude.
Yeah man and then just-
Fucking burning blunt dude.
On the back of my neck
so only people that,
when I'm wearing a pony tail
that's when they know
I love blunts.
And you'll get weed
inside your lip
so you say ah look at that.
Want to see, isn't that cool?
The thing that strikes me
with tattoos
though is that I go through
so many phases in life.
I'm shocked that your cousin
has always liked these things.
Because imagine
if you had tattooed stuff
that you like
when you were like 17?
I wish I would have.
I want to go get
a Dave Matthews tattoo
now that really faded
and raised really bad.
I want it to look like shit
but it be fresh
because I would have had
that had I been allowed to.
Yeah you can't get a freshy
Dave now.
I'm glad I never did
the ankh symbol,
I would have unicorns
and ice skates and ponies.
That's all I liked.
Oh boy. And now I feel though
forever
I will always love
the things that I love now.
That's not true.
That's huge, that's great
that you know yourself.
Narcissistic men.
Love, love.
Love.
Micro-penis.
Instagram. Just tattoo
the Instagram logo.
Just get it on the side
Andrew they won't be able
to fit it all but ...
Write micro on my dick.
Yeah people who get tattoos
on their penises.
Or if you get
your clit pierced.
No thank you.
I mean part of me wants
to just feel
what it would feel
like getting it pierced.
I think that would be
a great feeling.
It would be painful
but also probably pretty dope.
Especially if you get it in the
middle of the mall at a kiosk.
Piercing Pagoda.
It's a teenager with a gun.
One of those clamp, clamp.
Yeah just get up
on this chair here, yeah.
Don't mind the people
in Spencer's.
That's the problem the guys
who has to pierce your clitoris.
Did you have a stroke?
He's gonna like hold it,
that would be so weird.